alright guys bangbang a very special
treat today I have planned be with us
you have become a legend on the Internet
sir so thanks so much for coming on and
doing this yeah Thank You Anthony thanks
for having me
ok so many people know you as the
Twitter account that took the internet
by storm and just started dropping tons
of graphs and charts and all of this
kind of intelligent analysis of Bitcoin
and Bitcoin price etc but you actually
have a real job like a day job maybe
tell us a little bit about your
background and they kind of what you do
day to day today sure I can go a little
bit further than I've done in the past
so I'm a Dutchman which you might hear
I'm mid-40s and I'm an institutional
investor so I have a day job full time
job twitter is a an evening and weekend
project for me but yeah the investing
part is what I do I have an economics
degree and a law degree economics in
quantitative finance and a law degree in
bank bank of financial markets law
actually my first job was at a dealing
room in Germany where we did Avex
trading and I got to know all the
technical analysis indicators which
which was really fun and and and there
were a lot of them so actually that was
also when I experienced my first crash
in 1998 the Asian Tigers went belly-up
also Russia I think and and some hedge
fund long-term capital management with
all the Nobel Prize winners in it
so that was it that was a frightening
experience right then
and from there I moved to banking and
where I was responsible for asset
liability management and
capital management from a small bank but
it was a totally different game from a
dealing room where you were responsible
for well maybe a couple of million at
the bank it was a couple of billion and
wow yeah that's a couple zeros but it
also changes the whole game
and yeah there I experienced the 2000
crash the dot-com bubble i when it
popped and also the aftermath with
regulation in Europe that was Basel
capital regulation
Vasil a2 at the time so we implemented
that and and after that I I moved on to
pension balance sheets so life and
pension balance sheet and the fun thing
there it's even bigger than bank balance
sheets so this was a tens and even
hundreds of billions of assets to manage
a lot of mortgages in there so that was
one of my main assets on the balance
sheets did a lot of securitization
especially with my legal background I
was quickly drawn to structured finance
so basically all the stuff that that you
see in the in the big short movie that
could be that was literally my 2008 year
and yeah I really learned a lot of that
because a 2008 I think everybody who
worked in investment and and and was
close to the fire sort of knew what was
coming because sprats were were widening
and and yeah it wasn't a total surprise
and what was a total surprise was what
the central bank's did after that the
quantitative easing that started and and
the very low and even negative interest
rates in in Europe so that yeah I I
experienced that from from my job from
on a day-to-day basis but it also made
me question
the system and and it may be looking for
for hedges and and and alternatives Plan
B's if you will for for for the assets
that we had on the balance sheet and and
that's how I came across Bitcoin I
actually read the white paper in 2013
it's a little late but still it hooked
me from the start but the price was of
course very high in the end of 2013 it
just went 10x and I didn't buy and and a
year later it was it was a hundred
dollars again so my first investment in
in in Bitcoin I was a private investment
not not as an institutional investor was
in 2015 and that's also when I started
working the Twitter accounts for for
information just just lurking
information not not actively posting my
first post was actually the March 2019
article about stock to flow and while I
have from then on it's it's it's a it's
yeah crazy seventy thousand followers I
did yeah it's it's hard to do it next to
a normal job and but I I manage till now
see what that goes we're sure so one of
the things I want to talk a little bit
more about is you said that in 2008
housing crisis those who were kind of
close to it saw it coming maybe explain
that a little bit more and then talk
through the things that those who saw it
coming what did they do it kind of how
they weathered that storm and then we
can get into kind of what that might
mean for potential situations you know
today yeah well especially those close
to the RMBS
and and the the housing investment the
mortgage investments they saw it coming
because yeah what you do is you chop up
for mortgages and and you structure them
in a way
that results in a mortgage bonds and you
sell them and the spreads on those
mortgage bonds and and what what goes in
those mortgage bonds is it was changing
over time so it went from from very good
quality to a little less quality to
really really bad quality especially of
course in the US but as European
investors you could see sort of what
what was in there and and and also you
saw sprats why they saw the credit
default sprats of a lot of those come
companies and if spreads wide and that
means the risk is is is is increasing
and something is is increasing some yeah
something is going on and and you don't
know what but you you know there's
volatility coming and I sometimes
compare it because it's it's it's really
easy to say that with hindsight so I've
really saw it coming
that was close but it's the feeling is a
bit bit like today with the negative
interest rates and very low interest
rates in the u.s. that you yeah you
somehow know this is not normal you
somehow know this can go forever but
well yeah you have to invest in you your
your part that's part of your day-to-day
job and that was the same in 2008 got it
and and so when you came across Bitcoin
coming out of that situation you
described a little bit about reading the
white paper but was it a hey this is
interesting but no way it'll work or was
there some other reaction that you had
because I think that your experience
especially given kind of a very you know
high degree of knowledge and expertise
in finance and institutional investing
et cetera there's a lot of people in
your seat who had the same reaction so
maybe talk a little bit about that yeah
I was hooked from from the start just
from reading a white paper so I've read
the white paper I guess 10 times I
couldn't believe what was there so it
was really the white paper only that
that that got me into it
and I I was amazed by the elegant way
that they that Satoshi had to solve a
very complex problem that many people
have been going after for a long time
how to make a digital scarce good I have
to say scarce yeah so digital scarcity
the fact that he he succeeded in in
making that with the computer program
that he wrote and and and with the
hashes and the cryptography and the
proof of work yeah that got me from the
start
so that was that the technical part and
immediately as an investor you start
looking well what's what's the return
what what is something like that worth
and then even in 2013 you could see the
major asymmetric return risk return
profile which is just like having four
four investors you don't see that very
often and I know the volatility in the
wild swings might scare the less
experienced investor but especially the
quant investors they they'll know how to
deal with the volatility if if the
return is big enough and well if you're
talking about Bitcoin you're talking
about an asset with and Sharpe ratio
bigger than one and and actually I don't
know of any other asset with a Sharpe
ratio that's bigger than one meaning
that a return percentage is bigger than
the the the risk percentage and to give
an example
I mean Bitcoin can can crash once in a
while then it goes like 80 plus percent
down so that's the risk 80% but you get
rewarded for that risk with a on average
200% returned well as
if you calculate that and we'll talk
about that later too for sure but that's
that's an amazingly good risk return
profile so that yeah so you start
thinking how to slice and dice that how
to structure that how can we size
investments that have less volatility
also less return but keep this very
juicy asymmetric risk return profile so
yeah from a technical point of view the
invention of digital scarcity as from an
investor point of view the asymmetric
risk return it was something I needed to
know more about and and actually that
that was for me that was a very easy
route I never touched things I shouldn't
touch I never got scammed or lost
bitcoins I just followed the the route
that the the white paper laid down in
the references there is of course Adam
back he's very active on Twitter so I
started following him very fast you can
see who he is following and and and
retweeting and stuff so you got to nick
szabo and Andreas Antonopoulos and and
well all the all the bitcoiners and so I
took it from there and yeah I think I'm
in it almost 24/7 as far as my job
allows it but almost 24/7 ever since I
love it and so when you read the white
paper in 2013 you didn't really do
anything you said until 2015
what was what was kind of the the logic
behind waiting for 2 years right so you
kind of intellectually got intrigued and
curious was that a price thing was it
something else why wait yeah well it
isn't easy for someone to buy his first
Bitcoin and also for me I had to figure
out wallets and where to buy it and
stuff
and and it took me about a month to read
and and and and then be ready to tube I
was I think November or December but
then the price was already up ten times
10x I think in a month it was one or two
months
exactly just one or two months that I
needed to to prepare myself and yeah
well that my experience tells me that
then you're a little late
and you might might better wait for some
better opportunity although I didn't
have stock to flow mall or any other
model at that time my my gut said just
just wait a little and maybe this is
yeah well I'm too late and was basically
the feeling where of course a year later
in 2014 when it crashed again to $200
and I thought oh yeah well not okay then
yeah I'm glad I didn't do it because
it's dead and then it went from a
hundred to 200 and and from 200 to 300
and then I started thinking wow it it
went two weeks from the bottom and it's
rising again this is the moment boom so
I went in yeah that's awesome
and so when you started to do that
obviously you've made it an investment
and a whole Bitcoin personally but for a
day job you work at a fairly large
institutional asset management firm or
institutional investor but you guys
along with pretty much you know 90 plus
percent of institutions in the world
have not added exposure to Bitcoin maybe
talk a little bit about you know that
balance between your personal opinion
and and risk exposure or risk appetite
and then what you have to do
professionally you know as a large
institution and how you balance those
two yeah that's a very interesting topic
to just to say upfront I'm not the only
one who has Bitcoin in the company I
think my boss has Bitcoin
or 90% of my colleagues have Bitcoin
especially the quants but also the
investors themselves and but there is a
big difference between investing your
own money and investing someone else's
money which is basically what we do
professionally if you manage someone's
pension money bitcoin is not the first
thing maybe you think about although I
think that could be a very nice fit but
the the main classic assets that we
invest in for pension money is of course
fixed income assets like like bonds
mortgages consumer loans everything with
with interest that you need for paying
the pension so things like especially
things like like commodities gold and
and Bitcoin is like that there is no
dividend yield there is no return and in
in in an interest it is not a very
logical fit and and that's I think we're
we're a big differences and the other
thing is the capital regime the
regulation so you have a regulator as a
bank but also as a pension company and
regulators a they have a regulation that
that this that determines how much
capital you have to hold for each asset
class and the more riskier the asset
class the more capital II after hold so
you know bitcoin isn't even on the list
so it probably gets the highest capital
charge that's there which is okay
because there is a return against it but
but it doesn't really fit that
regulatory capital framework and this
and the other thing is regulators of
course
the central banks we're talking about
there they're not all that fond of
Bitcoin I think there's more there's
central bank system there are more open
to Bitcoin and crypto or
cryptocurrencies and I think that Dutch
central bank is it's one of them by the
way so they're very open door Congress
and they they talk with FinTech
companies and with pension funds and
banks they have a very large Congress
every year no it's not every year
because it's once every year every
several years and I went to one so that
there's a very open discussion with with
the regulator with a central bank but
it's not an easy fit and it's also not
something that is yeah let's say that a
good topic to talk about in the meetings
you have with the regulator and that's
also one of the reasons I'm anonymous
because I don't want my Bitcoin hobby to
to be of negative impact for my my
current employer and yeah the other
reason of course is operational security
think so she gave the perfect example
there but yeah it's it's by the way one
of my dreams to to be the bridge between
the exotic bit going world as it is
right now and the more traditional
finance world an investing world that
I'm in with with my other leg because
yeah I think I'm am in perfect position
to be that bridge and to start those
discussions so so I'm I've already
started those discussions which resolve
that is in some people buying Bitcoin
themselves just to look just to try just
to see what the asymmetric risk return
profile I could do for them and some are
very happy some are not so happy but
everybody's learning and I think it's a
matter of time before before you you see
the first
yeah banks and and pension companies
that have a balance sheet that invests
other people's money to go into into
into a Bitcoin although I do think that
the first more the first and the more
easy candidates will be funds just so-so
the asset management part of the firm
that we have they have funds and people
invest in those for their own risk so
it's not our general account that that
we bear the risk and that we have
liabilities pension liabilities on that
will be the second step I guess if the
fun business will be first got it and so
when you think through some of these
large institutions coming into the space
what are the arguments or kind of
talking points that you find are most
attractive to them or kind of resonate
the most versus maybe some bit that
don't actually pique their interest and
the reason why I say this to think the
Bitcoin community in general this is
more kind of the Twitterverse etc
there's so many narratives right is a
digital gold is it electronic cash it
could it be both all these things what
do you find that actually gets people to
pay attention especially in these
institutional environments yeah that's
that's a good question I gave a
presentation for the the the whole team
including our chief investment officer
at the end of last year about Bitcoin it
was a about a two hour presentation one
hour presentation and one hour questions
so what what what the the main thing in
their heads is said that the the the
picture they have of Bitcoin is shaped
by mainstream media and and the the big
financial media firms like Bloomberg and
you know I know how Bloomberg talks
about Bitcoin at the moment it's it's
it's it's it's not very good so so
they're they have
this point of view that it's it's for
criminals that the government will ban
it that's it's polluting the
environments and so they have a very
negative view and I talked about one of
the things that we bit going us talk
about things like it's it's an
asymmetric risk return profile it is an
uncorrelated assets or not a safe haven
asset or negatively correlated asset but
uncorrelated asset which is better in my
view because safe haven assets go down
where the other things go up and this
this thing goes up no matter what so so
that and and also and that surprised me
a little bit the futures market at the
moment if you look at the futures market
for gold for example they are income
tango meaning that the future gold price
is higher than the current cult the spot
core gold price and and this is actually
something that we do that we we did a
cash and carry trade with gold where you
buy the gold and Senate a month or a
couple of months later for the premium
but if you do that with gold you get 1%
and if you look at Bitcoin and the
futures on Bitcoin you can earn 1 to 2%
per month so that's actually yes well
somewhere between 10 and 20% lately
cash-and-carry returns so with with very
little risks because everything is
collateralized so 20 percent 10 to 20
percent cash-and-carry return on your
investment and and that got some ice
pops and and and and we had a lively
discussion about that still still still
having that discussion by the way yeah
and so it's really interesting because
when you mentioned in gold there's a lot
of work that you specifically have
that I think people could upcoming and
say oh that applies to assets like gold
as well maybe let's start with the stock
to flow model and you can kind of walk
us through what is it why does it work
and really how it works so that people
that have seen the charts really can
kind of get the the explanation behind
yes yeah so what what what I'm trying to
do is is shape the Bitcoin world and the
investment view in in terms that we're
familiar that we as investors
institutional investors are familiar
with so the Sharpe ratio that I really
mentioned but the other thing that's
really missing I thought that was
missing was it was a fundamental model
and and and well that that's true for
gold as well a little bit because there
is no fundamental valuation model for
gold other than the cost of production
of gold and and something similar was
there for for Bitcoin as well but for me
that that wasn't enough so I've started
actively looking for fundamental models
for Bitcoin and I encountered only
technical analysis models and well
having worked out dealing rooms Technic
analysis is nice and it's it's yeah it's
kind of a language to to talk in the in
the trader community and it describes
situations etc etc but they don't really
Wow maybe I shouldn't say that they
don't really work well all the time and
it's very difficult to at least
mathematically are statistically
benchmark them and program them in a way
that that institutional investors
understand because institutional
investors like banks and and and and
pension as a managers they they don't
really use the technique analysis so
stock to flow is a yeah it is it's
actually an attempt to quantify the
scarcely scarcity digit
scarcity invention that sitar she made
and Gogol was the nearest acid I could
think of and I'm following gold actively
for years actually I am an old gold book
before I was in Bitcoin and so I knew
about stock to flow as a ratio of the
amount of gold that's there above ground
right now and and the amount that's
produced every year and an in gold at 60
around 60 so there's 60 years of
production above ground and that's
really high because for all the other
assets silver Pilate and planting
Heights it's really low even even close
to one so not very much stock so I was
reading safely in a Moose's book the
Bitcoin standard and and he's talking
about stock to flow as well but then in
a Bitcoin contact so that made the click
for me like hey I could use the stock to
flow concept that's well familiar thing
in the gold community I can use that for
Bitcoin as well and let's see how that
how that calculates so I I made the
model and calculated stock to flow for
Bitcoin over the last years and and and
well sort of correlated that plotted
that first against the price and that
was this very nice straight line in the
logarithmic space so yeah from there it
was a small step to go to the formula
that that is familiar now and that's the
stock to flow model that that came out
of there and that that's actually the
first time I had some anchor some some
fundamental statistical model that I
could rely on to say something
intelligent about about the price and I
was very happy that this model was was
verified by others by many others I
might say and especially the the
addition of cointegration that Nick from
Australia did was was was crucial
because I talked about a walker
integration in very different terms
because I noticed from the model that
every year the price of Bitcoin was
below and above the model it was very
tied to the model so every year it was
above and below and and in mathematical
terms in statistical terms it's you can
quantify that by by cointegration which
is what he added and it was that was
really if you want to know more about
that he did in a podcast with the staff
and the viewer lately
make sure you listen to that and then
later on the model when it was published
it got some real attention and and
others Vera fighters as well like like
guys like Marcel burger from from burger
capital but also a manual phone and by
Ann Landers Bank and Mark from the gold
fund incremental so it's really I think
about ten guys that that checked the
model and all came to the same
conclusion which gave real confidence so
yeah I'd if it's it was the thing I
needed to take it seriously as a
professional investor and and it was
also something that could be replicated
and and checked by others yeah well
that's another important thing the only
thing is that that the outcome was
rather well shocking it was rather high
because it predicted like you all know
the a fifty two hundred thousand dollar
Bitcoin price after the next halfing and
and that of course yeah it it makes you
wonder why why that is why it should be
so easy to make a 10x on your investment
that that's normally not that
that actually can't be possible and it
also makes you wonder why the model fits
as well as it does so I think that's the
interesting question and a lot of the
discussion on Twitter is going about
that so first of all I think why does
stuck to flow work yeah because it
measures scarcity directly like gold so
you can sort of compare it with gold in
stock to flow terms but also in in
market cap terms and the scarce or
something is this yeah the more valuable
it should be so that's that's one thing
that that's point I started with but
another reason it works very well could
be the network effects that that we talk
about a lot with in Bitcoin so there is
the the network effects of developers
that more and more developers start
working on Bitcoin and and more and more
merchants start buying stuff and selling
stuff with with Bitcoin and investors a
number of investors keeps increasing and
then there's all sorts of network
effects in markets where you have in the
beginning you didn't have on ramps and
off ramps now you have exchanges in
every country and and you have even
derivatives markets future markets and
and option markets and not not very
exotic ones but but in Chicago see me or
in New York the bucked futures those are
very important and does build over time
so it could be that the stock to flow is
is quantifying the underlying network
effects in in Bitcoin but but another
reason is its quantitative easing is
what one of the reasons I started
looking at a Bitcoin in the first place
is look the central banks have
printed trillions of dollars since the
start of Bitcoin which is also the exact
moment of the of the global financial
crisis of course so they have started to
print trillions of dollars and euros and
yen's and this money goes somewhere I
mean I can see it in my day-to-day
business they'd that money is used for
buying bonds that help States of course
but it's also used for buying mortgages
and yeah so so so it could be that a
little bit of that money is somehow
finding its way into Bitcoin and that
Bitcoin measures the yeah the the
increase in money supply if you will of
all those fiat currencies and yeah I I
have tweeted once that as long as the
central banks keep printing the Bitcoin
keeps rising it could be some truth in
that too and maybe a fourth point is why
does stuck the flow work it only works
if you have hot Lars
so the outlaying of course is a there's
a term in Bitcoin that everybody uses
but it's it it's it means that there are
people that really believe in Bitcoin no
matter what somehow sometimes so they
they stick to it they they keep the bit
going through crashes and there are the
real hot lawyers are you need the hot
laws to create a high stock to flow
value of course it's like companies that
prefer very loyal shareholders that you
know if there's a crisis or something
going on they don't immediately sell
your stock and split up your company and
but let you build that if they have the
vision that you have that does already
ideal stockholders shareholders and the
same is true for for Bitcoin I guess
against the holding the hot nurse and
the holding the act of holding is very
important and might also be something
that is quantified by doctor flow how
much of the stock the flow model do you
think that like the accuracy of it is
derived
from this programmatic scarcity so
scarcity is one component obviously gold
and Bitcoin share but the idea that the
scarcity is so programmatic and
predictable does that hold that stock to
flow model kind of hone in on the
accuracy or does that not really play a
part you think I don't know I don't know
it certainly helps with a prediction of
course because it helps if the the
variable that you used to predict if
it's mathematical thing and and is it's
deterministic it's it's we know stock to
flow for four hundred years to come so
that really helps with predicting
something that you don't have a
stochastic variable there so yeah and
and what you also see is that the the
relationship the cointegration is
getting stronger over time so that's
very interesting and and and a mere
recent discovery but the cointegration
is getting stronger and stronger so it
will be very interesting to see how that
holds off the next whole thing yeah and
describe that a little bit more for
those that are unfamiliar with
cointegration and kind of how that's
calculated and why it's important maybe
just unpack them yeah I think a lot of
people don't understand what
cointegration is and and I don't blame
them because it's a ray it's one of the
exotic things that even if you study
econometrics you get maybe in your last
year if you're lucky
so cointegration it's it's it's actually
a technique from the mid-80s so it's
already 40 years old it was invented by
Granger and angle mr. Greene Shangri got
the nobel price for it and it why did
they did they come up with this
cointegration formal our technique it it
was it was a solution for a economic
problem that they had in the mid 80s and
that was that there was a lot of
spurious regressions so
in the 80s who had when their computers
of course went mainstream everybody was
running regression analysis on economic
time series macroeconomic but also a
financial markets and then yeah you
could correlate those those time series
and draw all kinds of conclusions from
there but the big problem from with with
time series analysis and especially with
regression is that there's there could
be spurious regression so you find a
correlation a very high r-squared and
but it says nothing it's just the
spurious regression and and they made a
lot of mistakes with that so angle and
Granger came up with his technique to
test if the Greek ration was spurious or
not this is very very useful and
basically what they did is is modeled
the difference between two trending
series and by training series I mean
time series that go up or down that are
non stationary as we like to say so for
example stock to flow is something that
goes up all the time you know that and
and so it's it's trending up and the
same is true for for the price of
bitcoins so so start to flow and bitter
and I both training up and if you run a
regression on those series you always
find a very nice fit and a high
correlation but most of the time that
correlation is spurious so what in fact
you should do is test for Co integration
and and if you find cointegration then
you know it's it's not spurious so what
is cointegration cointegration is the
difference between two training series
and if so so for example the stock to
flow model has the
this step function that we all know and
and Bitcoin is is it's moving around
that but it stays very close to the to
the model value and what you do is you
analyze the difference between the model
value and the actual bit current value
and if that difference is stationary
which means it they did it
it is sort of it's normally this
actually if you look at the at the
residuals of the structu flow model it's
it's it's a normal very nice normal
distribution of the errors of the
residuals and so yeah it they stay
together and that's that's what it is
the popular story that goes with it is
the the story of the drunkard a dog so
the the drunk is is walking in a random
way because he's drunk and as dog is
also walking in a random way but they're
connected with the leash so the
difference between although they are
both walking a random walk if you will
the difference between the drunk and the
dog is stationary is sometimes high
sometimes small but but it it there's a
relation in the day so they are
cointegrated and yeah how do you
calculate it you need a special
statistic package for that so that could
be our or start our eviews and but you
can also do it in excel if you know what
to do and yeah i have a tweet about that
but it's quite technical but you can do
it in excel as well you just have to
measure the distance between the two but
between the model values and the actual
values and and and and run a regression
on that one so yeah obviously stock to
florrum bit current price are
cointegrated and and and and that means
it is not spurious it's real and all
other models that I know all other time
series that I know
are not cointegrated so that's that's a
very important finding I looked at a
charade I looked at difficulty at time
at that well every and the number of
accounts the number of active addresses
the number of bitcoins they all show a
very nice regression they all have a
very nice r-squared but none of them are
cointegrated so they're all spurious
except stock to flow and that is the
real importance of stock to flow above
cointegrated stock to flow a bit quite
price got it and then we think about the
stock to flow and cointegration has this
intersect with this sufficient market
that you've been kind of talking about
recently yeah yeah
yeah but I got a lot of critique of
course and and that's good that's why I
put it out there and didn't keep it for
myself and and trade on that or invest
in it so the critique was was wow
there's not the amount in there and or
it goes to infinity or there's only to
how things just does it doesn't work for
altcoins etc etc those critiques are not
very strong I think we we argued about
those a lot and and and I think they're
debunked all but but I don't know if
this is not the time to to do to to talk
about those but the efficient market
hypothesis is I think the Steelman
argument against the model if I were to
to argue against talk to floor I would
argue the efficient market hypothesis
argument and what it says is that if
free money doesn't exist so there's no
free there's no free lunch and and the
fact that you you use information that's
out there out there in the public and a
formula that is that is publicly known
means that everybody knows it or the
market knows it at least and and
that that could not be a source of it
that could not be a profitable thing
because it's out in the open and there's
theoretically actually three variants of
the efficient market hypothesis one is
the weak variant that says you cannot
use price data alone so univariate data
to predict the price of anything so you
cannot use historical data of Bitcoin to
predict Bitcoin that's the weak form of
efficient market hypothesis and it
basically says that technical analysis
cannot add value I think most investors
economists agree that that's true so the
weak form of efficient market hypothesis
is true then there's the strong form of
efficient market hypothesis at the other
end and that says yeah if you have
insight information for example about a
merger of a company that can be used for
making money and making profits and and
that's also why that is illegal to use
them for inside information and it's
important to note that not everybody
needs to know this inside information
even if there's one or a couple of
people knowing this information they
will buy or sell whatever that
information implies and they will move
the price with that buying and selling
so most investors and economists believe
also believe in the strong efficient
market hypothesis and where but where it
gets fuzzy is in the in in the third
variant of the efficient market
hypothesis that is the semi strong
efficient market hypothesis and that
tells you that even some not insider
information and out
price information but fundamental
information multivariate models like the
stock to flow model it cannot be used to
make a profit in the markets because all
that information is already publicly
known
so yeah that's
discussion is a little bit is a stock to
flow publicly known or is it known to
very few people and it's it's sort of
inside information to be honest and and
and and of course the discussion is then
is it priced in is for example the whole
thing that we will have in May this year
and and and they predict a 10x increase
in price by the stock flow model is that
priced in or not and in my view that is
that that's semantics
it's the efficient market hypothesis is
a misnomer actually it's it's not a
hypothesis it's it's not testable you
cannot apply statistics to it so if
we're doing semantics I would say and I
did in the article that I wrote yes I
think the the stock to flow model is
priced in because it is built on stock
to flow information that's publicly
known and the formula is also out there
and and like inside information not
everybody needs to know it but if like
1% of my followers knows it or some
Baker and investors know it well you
know it so and I know it so we we will
use that information to move the markets
and so in that way it's priced in but
but again I think it's semantics and I'd
rather talk about something else that we
also professionally talk about and
that's risk we actually we never talk
about the efficient market hypothesis
when we invest professionally we just
assume it's there if it's a reasonably
efficient and big market like I think
Bitcoin is with 100 billion plus market
cap futures markets etc etc I also show
that in the article that it's it's it's
pretty efficient if you look at foreign
exchange rates and a bit
so if you assume an efficient market
then it's much better to just look at
the risks and are those risks are they
price in in a right way and there's a
couple of models for that capital asset
pricing model a black and Scholes option
pricing model that that that can be used
but basically it means that the okay the
stock to flow model with its high
prediction and its major opportunity is
known and it's priced in but there's
also all sorts of risks that people see
that the market sees that investors see
that are also priced in and some of
those risks are for example the
government ban that all my colleagues
are afraid of or the the futures
manipulation that's something that a lot
of people on Twitter talk about or the
mount Cox or plus token scam people
selling pressure that that's a big risk
or minor capitulation it's it's a and a
returning risk or narrative every time
there's the offing and right now of
course that's the the coronavirus risk
that everybody is talking about so so
what I did it has that's actually quite
quite interesting I I did some polls the
last months I did three polls the first
poll was three months ago
I asked what is the biggest risk you see
and more than fifty percent said it's
the futures many manipulation through
futures and futures were introduced at
the top of the market the all-time high
in December 2017 so futures yeah start
to flow it might have worked in the past
but now we have futures and doesn't work
anymore in the future that's a real risk
that some people see then a month later
I did the same poll and another risk
popped up at first and that was the US
introducing draconic all
regulation and laws on Bitcoin or the
threat that they would do that and that
was the that was moonshine I think he he
threatened with a conical Bitcoin loss
so everybody was afraid of that the
futures were on the second place and
right now if you if you do the poll
right now everybody is afraid of the
corona fears and the fires is of course
a big risk but it shows you that there
is a recency bias in the risks so
whatever risk is is recent and and and
and a big thing now people overreact to
that so so so in the end they've to wrap
that up
I think the efficient efficient market
hypothesis it is yeah it's semantics you
better look at risks and and then if we
look at the risk I think the sort of
flow model might be a little bit under
estimated or there might be an under
reaction to start to flow and there
might be a little overreaction to the
risk that we see around us like futures
and laws and and the coronavirus got it
and so I recently had Ron Paul come on
the podcast and he really broke down a
situation where you know at a minimum
there's a global recession and slowdown
at a maximum so that looks more like a
depression and maybe let's not spend
time debating the merits of you know
what happens but just in the scenario
where there is some sort of slowdown in
the economy on a global scale Bitcoin
has really existed in the longest bull
market in history how do you look at
kind of that macro environment and any
changes there impacting stock to flow
the price of Bitcoin or any of the
things that you've been looking at that
have kind of continued to line up but
but could they change in the in those
scenarios where there's a
mm yeah
that's a big question what bitcoin will
do in an economic slowdown because we
didn't have that last 10 years so
bitcoin was of course created at the
height of the global financial crisis as
a result of the global financial crisis
and and yeah so we haven't had a crisis
to test it on but I think that it will
be a bit it might be a bit similar to
the internet so that the internet of
course was built as a protocol a
communications protocol that that kept
working under enormous machine nuclear
Wars so if all continent worse was taken
out then how does the message go from A
to B and it was this peer-to-peer
decentralized network and the protocol
that reroutes the messages around nodes
that have been taken out and but that
was messages and and bitcoin is a bit
like that at least that's that's how I
see it it's very decentralized there's
there's hundred thousand nodes at ten
thousand relaying nodes around the world
so even if there's really big crisis or
people die yeah like a nuclear war or
where something else happens that people
cannot go to work or cannot go to yeah
leave their house then who is who is
gonna maintain the the central bank
systems who's who's going to print the
money if you will create the money
because it's all digital but whose was
going to operate Swift Network who's
going to make the ATMs running and put
money in the ATMs and ink and all that
stuff so so there's a whole network of
companies and people
and costs as well related to the current
financial system and I guess in a
situation like that it doesn't matter
what happens
Bitcoin will relay transactions it will
keep working even even if all the notes
on earth are gone because there is also
notes in space there's satellites with
Bitcoin it with the whole bit with all
the Bitcoin transactions and that can
relay transactions so I yeah if you ask
me I think Bitcoin is made for a
situation like that yeah it's super
interesting because it's all these
things when we go and talk to the
institutional investors particularly
United States the non correlation to
other assets in kind of this belief that
it can be that chaos hedge has been
something that has resonated what's your
point
that there's been this bull market that
has kind of raged on and obviously we
see now central banks are gonna do
everything they can to keep that going
but but it's definitely an interesting
thought process I think but ultimately
we're gonna see what happens you know
what's also very interesting and I'm
maybe that's a question for you cuz it
must be very difficult for our Americans
to understand to really understand what
it is to live in a country where where
there's negative interest rates for
example in my country and in Germany the
whole yield curve from from from one
month to 30 years it's below zero
there's there's no interest rates you
pay money if you if you invest that's
that's a real situation and in America
you read about it but you don't feel it
it's a it's the only country where where
the yield curve is is still positive and
yeah you see that turning south rapidly
of course recently but but what if the
the u.s. is is growing sub zero with our
interest rates and there will not be any
country with with the positive interest
rates
what I see around me is that people get
personally very interested in Bitcoin if
they see that they get negative interest
rates on their on their money at the
bank which happens in Germany and and
happened in in in the Netherlands is
actually the day after that the press
release that that the banks go negative
interest rates I get calls from people
how to invest in Bitcoin so that would
be very very interesting if that
situation will will sooner or later be
be be also true for for us for sure and
it seems like I think I was reading
earlier today that the markets now
pricing a hundred percent probability
that the Federal Reserve's gonna cut
rates in about two weeks here there was
an over eighty percent probability they
would cut rates again at the next rate
cut and so now you get two rate cuts
here it's highly likely that the US will
be at or near zero you know the next six
weeks or so and then from there I think
you get this really interesting world
with it is unlikely that they will want
to go negative but they may have to join
the rest of the world right and kind of
what happens there in the United States
it's kind of defended zero to some
degree you know it's a weird weird place
to be yeah absolutely and especially
your president Donald Trump has of
course made some nice statements about
that that he wants some of that the
juicy and negative interest rate money
it looks like he's going to get it it's
pretty crazy so let me ask this what is
in your opinion as we look at Bitcoin
and a lot of these disciplines I think
you and I are very similar in our belief
in kind of Bitcoin as a system and how
it's designed and what the potential for
it is but what would you say the biggest
risk is right now for Bitcoin you know
so if it didn't work or
didn't succeed what would you say was
the most likely reason that would be the
outcome oh that's a difficult question
yeah I do think that that states nation
states especially the US is a big risk
because other countries and and actually
today India for example in South Korea
and Germany simultaneously got caught a
little bit more positive legally with
Bitcoin but the u.s. is not moving in
that direction so very drastic tax laws
very aggressive anti money laundering
and terrify nan Seng checks so I guess
it will be most difficult for the u.s.
to give up the reserve currency status
in the end that will be that might be
come a very nasty fight so I think
that's that's that's a very big risk but
you see at the same time other countries
may be taking advantage of that
situation and opening their markets and
be very clear legally
about Bitcoin and give it a giving it a
place as a regular asset so that's a
risk the future markets I don't really
see as a risk I mean I see it as an
opportunity and as a network effect that
strengthens Bitcoin because yeah well
you know as a miner you're very happy
with the future markets because you can
take the volatility out of your revenue
stream you can sell the the vicar's that
you expect to mine for the next Wow six
months at least and you can sell them on
the future markets and don't have that
that that exchange risk if you convert
it to dollars and so you can do that
with futures and and the buyers of those
futures are of course the the funds that
don't want a hassle
the keys and and and the storage and and
insurance so there is a bit of a premium
as you can see the future markets are in
contango and I think they're a very
natural place where miners and and
trekkers and funds meet each other of
course there is room for four
governments that same governments that
don't like a bit going to suppress the
price to manipulate the price like well
I think it's now a fact that they did
with gold but on the other hand that's a
very manipulation with derivatives like
future is this in my view it's it's it's
like pushing a ball under the water you
can do that temporarily but not all the
time and it and you can you could do it
long but you get tired and then it goes
up and you see for example with futures
with the spoofing they of course they
they hit the price down but but it made
an opportunity for real believers in
gold to buy the the actual physical gold
and and you've seen for years and years
that all the physical gold is going to
the east is going to China and India etc
etcetera and that's where it is right
now so
so yeah in in the end you'll you'll lose
if you if you manipulate the markets you
can do that temporarily but not all the
time so I don't think that is a big big
risk coronavirus of course yeah it's a
big risk now but we we've had viruses
lost last ten years like the swine flu
and and immerse and and and there was
another one I'm not a doctor I cannot
assess the risk really well for sure
will have an economic impact but yeah if
you look at it from an investment point
of view it it it's also very probable
that we over estimate overreact to do to
this this risk so I think in the end
what what the question that you have to
answer as an investor or a potential
investor
in in Bitcoin is okay there's all those
risks on the one hand and there is a
well sort of fundamental model or value
on the other hand stock to flow or
whatever and and what is that chance
what do you really think the the the
valuation model the stock to flow model
has a 90 percent of failure so even if
it if there's a 10 percent chance that
it that it that it's right regardless of
all the risks are but if there's a 10
percent chance that the the Bitcoin
value will go to 10 to 200 thousand then
it it might be an interesting battle
ready and and I think those are the
numbers that we we have to weigh
everybody has to do that in in context
of his own risk preference but 10%
that's a success kind of a chance I
think that's I think chances are higher
than that I really appreciate you taking
the time to to do this you have some of
the most clarity in your thought process
that I've seen in the space and then
obviously given your background it's
super cool to kind of see you balancing
that the personal you know interest and
frankly belief with the institutional
and kind of professional work that you
do so first of all just from everyone I
think in in the Bitcoin community thank
you the work you've done with the stock
to flow itself has been incredible and
then you know if people can want to get
into contact with you or find you is
Twitter the best way to do that yep
Twitter I'm on Twitter so that's Plan B
at a hundred trillion US dollars and and
I'm on what is it the github so there
are all the data and the articles and
also the models the formula they're all
open source so if people like to play
with them themselves please be my guest
and if you have questions please reach
out